what we're calling psychopathic which is
dissociative personality disorder
that's common that's not unusual the
estimate
when we look at this is around one in
200 people that's why i'm saying it's
common
people exactly
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a
consultant psychiatrist and the author
of a number of very influential books
including the chimp paradox he's worked
with elite athletes he's worked with
psychopaths his latest book is called
the path through the jungle dr steve
peters welcome to trigonometry thank you
for inviting me it's a real great
pleasure to have you on as i mentioned
some of the things that you've written
in the past have been incredibly
influential in our culture the way we
think about personal development
performance anxiety all sorts of other
things
but before we get into all of that for
anyone who doesn't know you have a very
big international audience who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey through life that leads you
to be sitting here talking to us
okay in a minute yes it doesn't have to
be a minute take your time take your
time um i'm a consultant psychiatrist so
i'm a doctor a medical doctor and i
trained in mental health having gone
through the system and then eventually
ended up doing um
work with psychopaths as you would
colloquially call them but before that i
worked a long time in the nhs the
consultant and i'll be working with
people with anxieties depressions many
of the the common illnesses that we
recognize and i ended up in forensics
on the back of that i sort of decided to
explain to people how their minds
function because what i found a lot of
people who came through the door didn't
need a doctor in my opinion they needed
to understand themselves understand what
was going on in their head certainly
didn't need medication and so that led
me to uh working half the time with
medication half the time with a model
the chimp model uh to try and get people
to start managing their minds emotions
thinkings behaviors uh and it escalated
so i teach at sheffield university um a
professor there
and the students loved the model they're
related to it uh so they're
really behind the chimp paradox they
push me to say you've got to write this
and put it in a book
so so what is the chimp paradox tell
everybody
if you look at the brain and
try and simplify it because obviously
it's very complex i'm a neuroscientist
and if you start doing this you could be
all weak trying to just make you know
something of parts of the brain so what
i looked at if you look on scanners
functional mri scanners
simplifying it you end up with three
systems in the brain
so
in the fetus do you want all this
science yes right in the fetus what you
find is within eight weeks the orbital
frontal cortex just above your eyes
which is like a primitive defense system
a survival system
it starts to develop eight weeks into
fetal life and in the center of the
brain there are lots of areas which
support the orbital frontal cortex in
making quick decisions for survival
but it does the thinking bit and the
final decision making so you've got a
leader and it calls on another team
which is i called it the computer system
because that doesn't make decisions as
such it just feeds back
information to sort of influence a
decision so that was two systems
what we've got as a problem as human
beings is um the third system came in
usually it's there but it's not
developed around two-year-old which is
why we we get infuriated with young
children who keep saying why
everything's why because that part of
the brain has now started to wake up and
it's now questioning
so you've now got a separate system now
the first system the quick fire one uh
impulsivity really it we share with
chimpanzees we don't actually share the
same system with orangutans gorillas and
bonobos which are all under the the
hominid great ape group we don't so the
chimp was peculiar um and that's been
published in 2018 but i knew this
talking to hominid specialists back in
the 90s they said there's something
really strange about us and the
chimpanzee
so i called it the inner chimp
because the chimpanzee uses the same
behaviors and attitudes and shares the
same emotions when we use that common
system
so that was where it came from but the
the system that came in a bit late to
the party the chimpanzee has it but
tends never to use it
and in fairness without sounding cruel a
lot of people don't use it they just
work with the chimp system so life is
very impulsive instant gratification no
really consequence or planning
but when we get to round two the other
system's got the chance to develop so if
we promote that in two-year-olds
three-year-olds foyers then we see that
system starting to battle back so i
called that the human system and that
was it that was the chimp model it was
saying we have this inner chimp which is
a machine which will act and think for
us
but we actually have arrived we start
around two-year-old
and that's when we start laying our
memories down so we don't actually have
memories until we're about four because
our system can't do it so we arrive as a
human and it's an alternative system to
the chimp
so you have two options you can either
let nature run its course and be
impulsive and work with that or you can
actually choose to work with a different
system which works on rationality logic
forward planning consequence very very
different approach to life
and the computer is just neutral in the
middle
so making it simple chimp human and a
computer that you can both access that's
neutral ground program it
but the chimp does have some benefits to
it like i'm reading the book by malcolm
gladwell called blink and he's talking
about the importance of instinct and how
a lot of the time your first instinct
about something or a situation
can often be the correct one and that's
where the chimp comes in yeah it's never
negative and that's the title the chimp
paradox it's your best friend and worst
enemy but if you start delving into it
and trying to understand what it's doing
it's always on side it's never negative
it's just that we don't know how to
manage it
so a lot of the work the chimp is doing
is trying to say if we do this we'll
we'll be okay whereas your job is to say
well hang on there's an alternative
we're doing it so the chimp's never
negative as such but if we allow it to
run it's working on jungle principles
so the chimp will work with dominance
behaviors it won't manage drives well
it'll just fulfill them
and it may be insatiable so for example
if food is probably the commonest i use
because many people struggle with that
we don't eat the right things we eat too
much generally
so you can see that's an out of control
drive and the chimp's not going to
manage it it's just something we've got
to eat to survive whereas our job is to
say well actually we don't need this
much food to survive and manage the
drive but the drive isn't bad
there's nothing bad about the chimp
it just needs managing it can be
destructive if you don't manage it and
why is it that we're never taught about
this steve why is it that we're not sat
down and
having this explained to us because i'm
someone who struggles with food and in
particular anxiety and the two are
linked and it's only when i was reading
the chimp paradox that a light bulb went
off in my head and your current book was
like oh my anxiety is just the chimp
that's being unleashed and i'm not
controlling it
and that's why i end up in the
situations that i do or i i behave the
way i do which are ultimately
destructive to leading a happy life okay
quick therapy now yes yeah one really
big thing is church
no no no you might need to support him
one of the things you just said there is
is almost like a fatal error so i'm
being a bit severe to try and drive the
point of course you use the word control
you can't control yeah so if you keep
saying i can control my chimp there's an
implication you're failing in some way
once you use that word so i avoid that
word like the plague and i keep pushing
that in the new book to say you manage
the chimp which is a skill
so you're never going to control your
eating and you never control your
anxiety i don't want you to i want you
to manage them
but i think what you're implying
immediately is that this battle going on
well actually doesn't have to be
perceived that way
it can be you the chimp is your best
friend and he's saying to you i'm
getting anxious right you're not getting
anxious it's being imposed upon you but
instead of saying right there's this
anxiety
you need to step back and say what is
the chimp trying to tell me
because the chimp sees the jungle
so therefore
like with athletes i work with if you
said they're going out to compete you
expect the chimp to panic that's pretty
normal and healthy because it doesn't
realize it's just a competition as far
as it's concerned you're going into
battle i could die out here so they'll
get severe feelings of apprehension or
anxiety which the chimp will keep moving
with and if we then muddle ourselves up
with a machine and start saying i'm an
anxious person
then we can't work with it we can't
manage it because we're blaming
ourselves so it brings in lots of
feelings of failure and guilt and
instead of saying right we know who i am
we know the chimp is meant to be anxious
it's meant to do that it's doing a great
job and so instead of
being concerned or engaged in the
emotion we should be stopping saying
thank you for the emotion you've given
me an emotion let me explain what's
happening so you actually relate to that
part of the brain explain it's just
sport
you know and and then it depends on your
beliefs now because it gets complex and
i think one of the key things i'd say is
when people listen to this the biggest
thing i say to people is you're unique
only you can work out what's going on on
your head
so the anxiety message from the chimp in
sport for one sports person may be very
different message to another one
so when i work with people i've got to
work out what is it that their chimp is
trying to tell what's their brain trying
to say
so as an example to try and bring it to
life you you too could be elite sports
people both doing the same event let's
see
likely
we're using our imagination so if you
were elite sportsman say the 800 meters
yeah and you both said we're getting
really too anxious before it and it's
just terrible and that's making decision
making in the race poor which is what
you'd expect because the chimp said i
don't want to be here so it could go
anywhere but when you say why are you
why is your chimp getting anxious what's
the message for you it could be that
this defines you yeah and if you fail on
this everybody knows that you're
actually failure so your chimp i'm being
extreme again to arrive the point no
that's totally different to yours which
may be i'm trying to please my coach my
parents
and you start thinking well hang on
that's very different reason the chimps
are getting anxious so i can't then give
you right this is what we'll do i can't
do that maybe others spot psychologists
who the specialist can what i have to do
is try and delve into your mind and work
with you and say what's really going on
and what are the underpinning beliefs
here what's the agenda that your chimp
is bringing to the table
so often you'll get sports people trying
to prove to themself
where you may get another group trying
to prove to others and that's very
different again so the work i'd do then
would be well let's look at self-esteem
in the formal one and say why do you
need to use sport to do that
and in the latter one you've got to
start saying well why would you want to
prove your valuable um abilities to
other people why do you want to
demonstrate it what's going on
so so you get different approaches and i
ca i can't work with a
formula
i have to work with the individual
so steve
we've got we're talking about anxiety
and we've got the chimp and the chimp is
always anxious because it's there to
spot dangers to spot probably not i'll
keep correcting you because yeah correct
it's not always anxious it's getting
anxious when it perceives there's
something not right okay right so it's
perception if something's not right but
that because that could be because
you as the human haven't done your job
in tidying the computer up so there may
be a belief that's prodding the chimp
the chimp maybe just sat back relaxed
and then suddenly what i'm calling the
gremlins the destructive beliefs it
holds product
so for example let's say we go back to
that which is common someone has low
self-esteem they don't feel as good as
other people they're always feeling like
vulnerable right so that the chimp now
puts in the computer you're not actually
as good as others and you will be found
out so in business people i meet this
every day and it'll be impostor syndrome
you know they wake up in the night often
that's when the chimp said it's most
active and the humans asleep and then
they feel this devastating emotional
gut-wrenching feeling that i cannot do
my job they're gonna find me out i'm
gonna make mistakes i'm fraudulent i'm
an imposter
the chimp is doing its job when it does
that
what should be happening is when we wake
up we have to say right what are the
beliefs in my computer here
you know one of them can be that um
people who do this job are perfect
which is ridiculous uh and mistakes are
things that can't be redeemed
you know and now i've got to tease out
because it could be you've got a boss
who says you make a mistake you're
sacked i'd probably say get another job
but uh but but you can see why that
belief is in there but if the belief has
come from you and the boss is saying
look if you make a mistake
we make a mistake but until you turf
that belief out
the chimp's innocent it's not getting
anxious it's this little gremlin it's a
belief this needs turfing out so i like
to tidy computers up in people and i
usually explain that if i've worked here
with one of you i would expect to find a
minimum of five quite serious gremlins
that you're holding on to which are
causing problems
so in your case if you're saying i
struggle at times my chimp gets anxious
and i get this anxiety state imposed
upon me that you'll guarantee that
you've got probably at least five or six
very powerful beliefs which are really
destroying you
and and you're probably not aware of
them until they get pointed out and you
think ah probably i'm thinking that and
then we turn them over
does that make sense that makes complete
sense so i'm just gonna go guys
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
so that being the case what
what happens with a panic attack
is that
the anxiety becoming too much is that
the chimp overriding everything and
going into a sense of meltdown well
panic attacks
have different causes
but probably the commonest cause is
um something has happened an event has
happened in your life which has not been
addressed
and you haven't processed the event
either
practically or mostly emotionally
so i can give you an example of of a
situation where you might get a panic
attack and this is fairly common so i've
seen this many times
you get we do get sudden deaths in
people in the 40s very unexpected rather
tragic but if you've got a best friend
who's in the 40s who dies suddenly and
you've never really thought about your
own mortality
suddenly it comes to your like front of
your mind and if you don't address that
and just squash it down
the mind now starts to kick so this is
the mind saying well you've not
processed this so in reality the
computer's behind most of this
because it's saying this is unprocessed
material so it throws it back which then
creates the chimp
saying there's something wrong here and
and we have to look at you look at your
own mortality look at put in perspective
what happened which is very rare for
someone in the 40s to die suddenly
but if you don't process that and your
belief is i'm now very vulnerable and
this could happen at any moment and i've
never really prepared myself
then you can imagine that every so often
you get this sudden a panic attack out
of the blue and it's your mind trying to
say you need to sort this out
the problem we got with panic attacks
get quite technical is um sometimes when
you find it you often can't find what
caused them
uh you can settle the machine down
so the computing chip can be brought
down again
just by simple techniques but ideally if
you find the problem the trouble of
panic taxes they have a ripple effect so
even when we sort the problem out say it
were that that was a problem and we
sorted out then what you'll find is you
still keep getting panic attacks so
people say i'm not cured
it's not worked and you're saying well
no the way that a panic attack works
it's like a learned behavior so it keeps
on happening but it gets less and less
and you just manage them as the brain
presents it and you're trying to remind
the brain we have dealt with this
so there's ways of disengaging panic
attacks
and putting them in perspective
so pan's attacks are a bit of a peculiar
one
they're different and they're different
tracks in the brain to anxiety anxiety
and panic attacks use different
pathways stephen i spent most of my 20s
and early 30s kind of doing all sorts of
different personal development stuff and
learning to get out of my own way
and i found that very useful but i was
going to ask you how much of of this is
societal because for example for me i
know that one of the things that i had
to get out of my way in relation to was
um the feeling that
i don't want to stand out i don't want
to create a youtube show because then
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to see it and and i remember
reading something by desmond morris many
many many years ago in which he talks
about how the the fear of public
speaking is a very natural thing because
historically speaking
if if a bunch of your peers were staring
at you in silence that was not that was
not usually a good position to be in and
i think a lot of people feel some of
those things so if you want to be
successful if you think that you want to
create something that's going to make an
impact on the world it's going to
contribute to other people's lives in a
positive way how do you get out of your
way
so that you don't constantly watch what
other people might think or say or do
particularly in the social media world
that we live in now i mean everyone's
unique
so again i can't give you uh oh this is
the answer i don't want to do that and
maybe other people can i can't do that
so what i'd say is there are different
forces coming in here in your brain so
what you've got when i look at the
computer system is actually multiple
areas offering opinions
so for example intuition is a separate
part of the brain which reminds you of
what you've experienced and recognizes
it that's very different to the reward
pathway which says that i'm anticipating
this is going to be good news that's
very different to your anxiety tracks
which is saying this could all go wrong
so all of these previous experiences and
beliefs and opinions and behaviors are
all coming together and depends which
are the most powerful but the
fundamentally you're mentioning uh which
desert morris who was a zoologist in the
past was looking and saying are we just
the naked ape that was that was his
stance and there's truth in that i'm
saying the same thing it's not new we
know that we are part of the hominids
the troop drive
chimpanzees in the wild must belong to a
troop they cannot be alone if they're
alone they're very vulnerable from
attacks from other troops or leopards so
that's their main enemies so they're in
trouble so they must stay in troops so
what nature has done is given us this
drive to find and stay with the troop
but if you were the alpha male in the
troop you have to assess whether we're
worth keeping because if we're weak
we're using up useful resources for food
you you will exclude us so a weak meal
will be excluded and that's a death
sentence because another troops don't
like to take a meal
they might take females but they won't
take those so
if you think about it there's this
instinct that i've got to keep proving
myself to you
otherwise if you reject me i die so it's
extremely powerful so therefore our
chimp brain really wants approval from
the people around it but we've gone
further than that said our troops the
whole world so now we're feared of
everybody and everything they say
so i'll give a more personal example
when i uh used to teach the chimp
paradox modeling uh to students i was
doing that in the 90s i didn't bring it
out till 2012. um and that was because i
i feared in a sense my chimp was saying
well what the academics going to say
juventus
you know how ridiculous this noddy um
but it got to the point where my human
brain was sort of saying you know
really you can't not do this because i
know how powerful it's been for a lot of
people and that humbles me a lot and i
think i need to develop this and those
who resonate brilliant those who don't
find just throw it out with rubbish but
when i brought it out i had a chat with
my chimp
and i said here's the deal so i'm now
overriding the troop
because my chimp i've told not
everyone's in your troop so don't worry
about them so i select my troop
that gives me a protection from the
world so i don't see with all respect
you two in my troop i don't know you so
you're given a caution so your opinion
sounds awful doesn't matter to me you
can't affect me because that's what i've
learned as well it doesn't sound awful
at all you can't live your life by
worrying of what people do but most
people do and that's why social media is
very powerful but for me i said to my
chimp if 10 people write to say this
book has changed my life i would be so
happy i'd be so happy um and so my trump
agreed so i've gotten 10 people wrought
uh it was like that's it i always go
back to that we knew that there will be
people criticizing like saying none of
us want to be hit by the media of any
kind and drag through the mud or
attacked or belittle or because that's
something a chimp wouldn't want to do
for the reasons i've given you because
you're vulnerable suddenly and you want
to be in the troop and be loved
but one of the things i've pushed is
this to the one in five rule
you know we know that no matter who you
are somebody won't like you
so you know once you've worked that out
why are you worrying yeah it's true it's
about four and five for us but you're
right steve let me ask you something
else because you bring up what i have to
say one in five love you regardless yes
people need to know and there's a lot of
really great people around i'm just
kidding okay we have absolutely lovely
fans so i'm very pleased with what i was
going to ask you
is i think you bring up a very profound
thing about the world that we live in
today which is
the inevitability of tribalism yeah
and we see it in politics we see it
happening right now around the world
with all the different conflicts that
are kicking off and all of that we've
seen it over the last five years in this
country in terms of the political
landscape we've seen it in america we
see it everywhere
that tribalism is a very powerful
instinct in human beings for the reasons
that you've just explained
what can we do
in the modern world
to to to detribalize ourselves can we do
anything or do we just need to work with
it i mean i'm going back to what i said
originally this is the right at the
beginning when it was like a light bulb
moment to me back in the early 90s where
you're thinking wow these functional
scanners are showing me something here
that tribal instinct is not within the
human being it's within the chimp
and that's so important to distinguish
we don't have that
hence we have an alternative
that's why i said right at the beginning
when your brain develops nature's giving
us for whatever reason an alternative
and that's how we've got out the jungle
we've decided to work with our humans
which don't have prejudice which do
respect diversity which are peacemakers
in general you can have people who have
unpleasant humans we'll talk about that
the chimp's nice
but in general the rule is we have an
option here
so if i want to go with my chimp brain
it's likely to be divisive because it
will form little groups and and curry
favor that's what the chimp's meant to
do again not everybody's chimp does that
you know so but most are built that way
so we are yes we talk about i come from
this town or this city a football is a
good example
where you know this is my club and it
gets very passionate you know you've
joined that
um and i'm not saying that's wrong i'm
just saying like a beginning with food
the food drives amazingly good it keeps
us alive but it does need managing and
the same with the the uh joining
football clubs or whatever as long as
you manage it and recognize it for what
it is it's brilliant you know
long may it continue but if you get it
out of hand then it becomes tribal and
really unhealthy
so my question is concerning social
media because we've touched on it at
point steve what do you and look again
debunk all the nonsense that i'm
speaking
if if it's nonsense
i get a coffee
but
it seems to me social media
appeals to the very worst of the chimp
it appeals to instant gratification you
know
a state of anxiety constantly wanting to
be accepted
how do we live it in this world and keep
our chimps calm when we have access to
something that is trying to cut out the
human and he's always trying to activate
the chimp in a negative manner
again up to people what they want to do
one is disengage i don't do so for me
just i don't know what it says uh i'm
happy without it um but i'm an old guy
uh i think for young people it's tough
but i think going back to what you said
what do we really want to start
instilling in young people and i think
we're not doing this uh i'd love it to
see it happen is emotional skills to
start discerning well this is an opinion
it's not a fact
and and we will get facts
apparently presented which are
inaccurate
about us we'll also get comments made
which are unkind because there are
unkind people around there's quite a lot
of them so we're not going to change
those people we've got to learn how do i
manage them so i'm thinking emotional
skills to learn how to manage social
media really ought to be in
you know and it doesn't say we're doing
anything and and that
violence it is a psychological violence
on people can be
life
threatening
and as we know it it does people can
take their lives on the back of social
media comments
so we have to accept that many people
don't think it out they're just acting
chimp at it's worse and just attack
people without thinking what damage am i
doing here but some people have to
accept enjoy the damage some people
enjoy
going for people
and it's just what they do so not every
human being is pleasant
so you've got to be selective but i
think it's going back to what you're
saying is we have to learn that
surround yourself with a world that you
can live in
don't try and live in the real world
because none of us really belong in it
because all you've got are roaming
groups of chimps and we're never all
going to be on the same page so take
your world with you create your world
create the people you want in it
and then enter the outside world but
don't engage the outside world and take
and think it's going to be kind to you
that doesn't mean roll over and not go
into i've done that you i'm going out
there but i will surround myself
so i'm almost in a bubble when i enter
[Music]
does that make sense that's a bit not
that much no that makes a lot of sense
it does make a lot of sense i think it's
very important to have those people
around you and to create your world and
to accept that when you step into the
real world there's going to be
unpleasant people there's going to be
people who try and hurt you there's
going to be because that's reality yeah
now you used to work at rampton now
again correct me if i'm wrong there are
three high security
prison hospitals in the uk i can't
remember that but the other one is
broadmoor which is the more famous one
yeah
what was that like when you were working
with these kinds of people are they like
us by and large or are they very
different with the way they see the
world the way they approach things and
the way they behave and act
we have to be careful because um
a bit more education if you look neuro
scientifically at what we're costing as
someone who's psychopathic and we've
seen by that
they lack conscience
uh they write the rules for themselves
um they're very little empathy at all
so they see people literally as objects
and they'll use people
that's common that's not unusual not all
of them end up in ranked and many of
them are social psychopaths and you will
have met some you definitely will where
they will use people and it doesn't
bother them so they can be socially
presenting well but they have no
compassion and certainly no conscience
so the estimate
for when we look at this is around one
in 200 people that's why i'm saying it's
common
people exactly so you can expect quite a
lot of destruction and we know this we
know this
um so when we look scientifically
the big interest there's lots of areas
of the brain which are different in in
their brains the biggest interest came
years back when we looked at the
connection which is the chimp thinking
brain the orbiter frontal cortex going
into the amygdala now people have heard
the amygdala is a very uh powerful
battery of energy which does our fight
flight freeze and it has about 17
clusters of of neurons and circuitry in
there so it's very complex for a tiny
little structure but but one of the
big important parts is it influences our
chimp very heavily in giving suggestion
what it should do
the track that joins them technically
called the unsonic fasciculus is just a
white fiber track so we don't know how
this happens but if you look at the
normal or typical person i call them
then it's quite a big cross-section area
and when you go down you see little
connections
and it appears to be those connections
temper the message from the amygdala and
give us conscience apart as well as
other parts of the brain when you look
at the psychopathic brain
the cross-section is tiny and there's no
interconnections so there's a structural
difference we found
um but
you can get individuals who have a
normal brain and still have psychopathic
traits and they can sometimes be damaged
people now i'm not making excuses but
it's very easy for those of us who have
supported parents or reasonable
childhoods to say well what's wrong with
them but i think obviously the world
that i've entered i meet people who've
had really a rough time and i mean
really rough time as young people and so
the circuitry gets damaged but they
could actually present with what we
would say is a normal circuitry or
typical and we can get that to to come
around but there can be damage done in
young children we know that the first
about five six years of your life are
crucial to get the circuits in a lot of
areas
functioning fully and if they don't you
can't recover that
so these people tend to struggle with
emotions struggle with impulsivity and
it's structured in the brain so it's not
an excuse they start to learn to do it
but they did a disadvantage to the rest
of us steve i'm going to ask you you're
making a lot of sense and i'm going to
ask you a question that is controversial
okay
but it seems obvious to me
that the consequence of what you're
saying is how we deal with crime is
going to be affected by that
understanding if there are certain
people who commit certain types of
genuine evil heinous crimes
you're not going to educate them out of
that are you no you're not going to
explain it to them that this is not in
their interest or this is that's how
their brain is wired yeah
again i'm just simply fine to try and
get the message yeah so when you mention
brampton what you're looking for are um
two people are coming to rampton and
then you assess them and you say what
i'm looking for is has this person got
in a conscience that we can wake up or
empathy have they gone through a rough
time in life that we can compensate for
it and what you do eventually you work
with that person's empathy compassion um
conscience that's what you work with and
you build that up and yeah you can do
that and then you would
move these guys down
uh so they go into a less secure and
maybe you can get back into society and
don't forget some people under the
influence of drugs when they do these
crimes so you gotta you know as we
mature people can move ground not
everyone right not naive that's what i'm
getting at yeah
yeah right so what now we're saying
we've removed those we can't wait what
about the ones who don't appear to have
a conscience or empathy and will repeat
behaviors and they do then we work
differently there's no point in doing a
compassionate type program
because there's no empathy so they're
not they're not going to ever engage it
and the research shows this the more
uh psychotherapeutic work you do with
them the worse they get really yeah
there's no work where at the moment
they're trying to find it cognitive
analytical therapy got close but we
found it doesn't do any good and the
answer is well you're trying to teach
you know a dog to speak
um it's probably a bad example but
you're now cancelled
but um what we're saying and then you
can work with them on a behavioral
program because they won't do things
detrimental to themselves so if you say
right if you do this the consequence is
as follows then people will work with
consequences whether they're
psychopathic or not
whereas i hope that you know if removing
those who haven't got a conscience all
the rest of us can work up our values
our morals and and actually improve them
get them to come to the front of our
minds but yeah that the um what we're
calling psychopathic which is this
social personality disorder um that
individual from my opinion um you're not
going to do much because the circuitry
is not there right so that's why i'm
asking the question because we talk on
the show about societal issues things
that happen things that people talk
about things that happen in the news and
every time there's this terrible crime
for example uh a man tragically kills a
woman or something like this the the
narrative is always well we must educate
men or we must do this or we must do
that and i'm sure there's some value to
that for sure
but i i just always feel like we're
missing that one piece which is there's
always going to be people who are going
to commit these crimes and what we need
to do is make sure that people are
protected from them that they're not
released from prison because we're
really compassionate and empathetic and
whatever etc like what is your take on
all of that conversation
i think i'd agree that obviously if
somebody's repeat offending all the time
then which is what we do we determine
until we think they're safe and if it
never gets safe they stay so it's
detention for life um but you've got to
demonstrate that there's no change in
this person and you obviously do try all
the therapies you can you don't just
decide this is somebody psychopathic
will give up
you you do try but if you're thinking
where it's not getting anywhere i mean
it's a long process with assessments but
i think most forensic psychs and foreign
psychologists would agree that you know
if you've got someone appeased to have a
brain that just will not function the
way the rest of us do then it would be
unwise to
chat to them and do empathy and when
they're not possessed that
it's not a
sensible thing to use your time doing
where they will respond to consequence
but again
it's a big feel this and i think when
you start delving into you say there's a
man who's killed a woman
you've got to really delve into this
because um
you know yeah of course it's wrong and
it's heinous no doubt but you have to
start seeing other mitigating
circumstances
again i'm not excusing an act i'm not
excusing but i'm saying i can understand
doesn't mean i can't understand it and
again for a lot of these what do you
mean steve there'll be a lot of people
listening to this going what the hell is
he on about well if you've had a really
bad childhood let's say your father beat
you to a pulp every night uh and
continue this throughout your first 15
years um you're not going to come away
unscathed no you know it's exceptional
if you come out there smiling and saying
i can contribute to society you're
permanently damaged so you may you may
have anger issues
because you've been suppressed and
suppressed and so you've got this anger
against dad now i'm giving it
any very sort of black and white terms
here but then you can see somebody else
comes in like the boss who starts
representing your father and does it
again to you and you and humiliates you
demeans you on
you can see how the anger spills and
then we do get a true emotional hijack
and the person may even know what
they're about to do but as soon as
they've committed the act
it fall apart because they realize it it
wasn't the right thing to do
you know and i know people will say well
that's just an excuse but i feel like
saying well you know do we all act and
behave appropriately every day of our
lives because we all know when we're
doing something wrong
do we
start punishing ourselves for that
you know it's an extreme i agree so i
think i'm compassionate to begin with
but i will draw a line and say okay
compassion only goes so far and it's
really bad that maybe get beaten to a
pot by a dad it doesn't excuse you
killing someone
but it's a fine line i think you have to
take individual cases
and
we tend to use a word psychopath and
sociopath and we use them and we
interchange them
what is actually the difference between
the two generally speaking what is
understood is when we started really
looking at the mind which is probably
going 100 years now and we started
looking at these individuals that were
so aberrant and we were recognizing
features they all possess the big ones
i've given you and that's the lack of
conscience and lack of empathy so you
don't see remorse in them and repeat
behaviors um and we initially the the
feeling was that society has created
these monsters uh so there was this
thing we've created it because of like
the background to these young managers
described so they would be known as
social
problems so they were sociopaths so
society was the behind it
as we started taking this on as doctors
with scanners and started seeing the
brain and saying oh wow the neuroscience
is actually telling us these are
predisposed not predetermined but
predisposed to to acting in a way which
lacks compassion and empathy and
conscience then we start to determine
terminology change to psychopaths
so the sociopath and psychopath is
really about the etiology you know
what's the cause is it society that's
created the monster or is it the monster
was born and it's just acting out
and then to try and get neutral ground
we we classify them as dissocial
personality disorders
and that doesn't then give a an etiology
just says this is what the behaviors are
demonstrating the cause we don't know
and that comes back to what one of the
functions of ramped him was to
distinguish between the two and so if
somebody is socially being built can we
undo what society has created
you know can we take away the anger or
whatever it is that they're going
through or is it that you know this
appears to be genetic and born this way
i just think you've got to be very
careful and not jump to conclusions or
judgments and always assume you're going
to help someone and be compassionate
until it's proved otherwise and think
there's a point where you've got just
you know it's well that's the important
part once you get to that point then
you've got to lift the wall from your
eyes if that's what's been there right
your question occurred to me as you were
talking there uh evolutionarily speaking
what is what is the evolution rationale
for the existence of psychopaths is it
the that other troop of chimps over
there is probably going to get a random
mutation that creates a psychopath and
we need some of our own psychopaths to
go and defend us against their side is
that some of the kind of evolutionary
background to this like what's the what
is the point of psychopaths is what
happens well i'm outside my field yeah
but um
i think nature doesn't have to have a
function it's trying something else yeah
and remember that in past the psychopath
wouldn't survive
wouldn't they become the alpha male no
because they wouldn't be liked by their
subordinates yeah
so the psychopath won't survive they'll
be the truth will go for them so how how
how do we still have psychopaths and how
is evolution well we
almost cater now don't we excuse a lot
sometimes we
allow so and and we know that if it's
genetic which appears it's polygenic so
it means you can't you will true dr
psychopath won't breed psychopaths but
but this is genetic loading so any one
of us will carry some of the genes
depends who you marry um but obviously
now they don't get eliminated which they
would a thousand years ago they wouldn't
people wouldn't tolerate them was far
more violent then we we've eased off
i'm not saying that's a bad thing by the
way but i'm saying that the problem of
that is that there is a bigger pool
because again because they will be still
sexually driven they often have three
four five children
randomly whereas the rest society's
moving towards like two children three
children or less
so the pool is is genetically would be
getting larger right the future is
bright the future's psychopath that's
what's happening
they're multiplying fantastic but but
steve you you
and again
please debunk this i read the about
psychopaths that you know there's a
they're more likely to be ceos they're
more likely to be successful higher
chances well this is the social
psychopath because again it just because
you haven't got a conscience and no
empathy it doesn't mean
that you don't work to certain society
rules
so i said most people won't be ax
wielding maniacs they're they're really
rare they're exceptional but we do meet
people who just don't seem to have any
empathy or compassion that doesn't mean
that and there would be cluster under if
if we looked at this tract and say well
there you go this is a psychopath but
that doesn't mean that they necessarily
are damaging it just means they don't
have compassion or empathy so they won't
have a problem sacking people and saying
well that's they have to get on with
their life
you know they won't have that but you
can also get people who've got
compassionate empathy and still have to
sack people and say yeah it's upsetting
it's not pleasant
but isn't it therefore helpful like if
you're a surgeon if you don't have
empathy then you're not going to be
you're not going to be worried i just
protect surgeons
they're not psychopaths
but all but you know if you're in a
high-pressure situation and you don't
have empathy isn't it kind of a
superpower in a way well not really i
mean i'm i hope i've got compassion and
empathy but i still work
in which i do in settings which are
highly mostly charged mean
the world of a psychiatrist is not a
happy world clearly you know and you
meet again with tragedies complete
tragedies and messed up lives and people
struggling with mental health issues um
and we're empathic and compassionate
people but we learn to manage that
so you learn how to manage your emotions
rather than saying oh it's best i don't
have any yeah
i'm not sure that would work so i think
you use your empathy to say how is this
man struggling or this woman struggling
get i like to so when i teach you get
inside the head of the person you're
dealing with because that's when you see
the world as they see it and it really
changes your view once you see
somebody's world then you come out of it
in order to be able to help them and
give them insights or support
so yeah i mean i was once approached by
a boxing coach who said can you deliver
psychopaths because they want one of the
problems boxers have is they don't
really want to hurt the opponent and
they said that can sometimes stop a good
boxer in their tracks
and i said well a psychopath wouldn't be
a boxer because uh they wouldn't comply
they won't comply with the rules and
they won't do the training and they want
so you know it's not like they can
channel themselves in
they're disruptive they'll work to their
own agendas and rules so you won't do
well with a psychopath
they're not compliant that's really
interesting so what what do psychopaths
tend to like what kind of things do they
get into what kind of jobs do they do
like well there can be anything like i
say the you you may get doctors
who are lacking in passion empathy and
we've had this in the history of
medicine haven't we where you know
clearly
they've gone through the system and then
they're not caring and they're just it's
a career
so you'll get them in any any walk of
life
it's
it's just a lack of compassion and
empathy great they're everywhere and
they're multiplying fantastic
um
on a good front uh just as a positive
note it is interesting to show that as
society keeps progressing despite the
fact that they may be
proportionate larger we're actually more
passive
and uh peaceful than we ever were
and it's interesting at the moment it's
a bit uneasy
but this is the longest time in the
history of great britain that we've
never had a war there has never been a
generation that hasn't suffered a merger
war never
so that speaks for itself that society
is becoming a better place my concern is
what you alluded to earlier is the
psychological damage that's being done
which we've never had before
so the physical may be going down but
for me the psychological is rising and
that's a great concern
and i think you've alluded to it the
social media it's this sniping where
we're not really thinking about what
we're doing
so it's so easy to criticize someone
when you're anonymous or just add
another thumbs down or make some really
adverse remark that you think is quite
witty but actually could cut somebody in
half
so that's to me is the new danger it's
the psychological warfare that's going
on
hey francis would you like to learn
another language no mike already know
foreign language is perfectly boy gary
le biblioteca
you can't go on holiday mate without
knowing where the swimming pool is the
bible tech is the library you idiot
exactly you can never be too far away
from knowledge and sexually frustrated
librarians
for those of you who do want to learn a
language and connect with another
culture or maybe just brush up in your
spanish for the next holiday babble is
the app for you babble's 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babble designs
their courses with practical real world
conversations in mind things you're
going to use in everyday life like
finding out where the bibliotheque is
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts meaning real people so
you learn useful vocabulary and not
meaningless phrases like the ones
francis keeps uttering babel's teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italians and the other ones babel
is available as an app or online and
your progress will be synced across all
devices babel is offering our listener
six months free with the purchase of a
six month subscription with our promo
code which is trigger go to babble.com
forward slash play and use promo code
trigger for an extra six months for free
we're even gonna get francis on it you
might learn english
that's b a b b e l dot com forward slash
play promo code trigger i use babble and
look at me now your boy
absolutely perfecto know what i mean
gary
do you ever get worried steve the the
way that we're talking about mental
health in particular the way that people
use
something like bipolar which is a very
serious condition i mean you know better
than anyone but they almost use it as an
identity or you know
depre being a depressive becomes an
identity that somehow
it makes you more interesting that
you've got a badge to me i find that
a worrying symptom of society really
i mean you're right if you look at the
spectrum obviously a depressive illness
is absolutely devastating and people who
get it uh you know your heart's got to
go out to them because it is crippling
and and it's nothing they're doing by
the way again it's not attitudinal um
but having said that yes you're right
we're not naive to the fact that
somebody might present because it's got
gains you know if i'm depressed i can't
work and they may not want to work and
you know when we're not fooled by that
we're saying obviously people will mimic
like you said they have a label
and then they meet they may this is a
small number of people use it as an
excuse and that makes it hard for the
people who generally suffer these
illnesses
you know and that that's you know but
they're doing it for a reason
it's again you got asked why would you
want a label
you know what what are the gains and and
if it's like you know someone wants to
say i'm depressed because they're so
vulnerable and they feel by being ill
people will not attack them because they
feel like they're being under attack in
some way you can see that you could work
with them to say well hang on there's
different ways of perceiving yourself
and and getting support than to make the
illness model
so people do use an illness model
you know but it's a small amount of
people it's not big but they'll come to
the forefront because people see them as
being well you're just using this as an
excuse
to avoid something or gain something
we've become quite negative in this
conversation so let's finish on a
positive you've worked with a lot of
elite athletes helping them to achieve
better performances to get out of their
own way and that i think a lot of
people the question that they'd be quite
curious to know is
are these people who you are seeing on
television making millions and millions
of pounds playing in front of a hundred
thousand people every week whatever that
might be
are they mentally different are they
have they achieved some kind of higher
level of performance mentally or do are
they just people like us who just happen
to physically be able to do stuff that
normal people can't do i believe that
people like us yeah they're not making
millions farther some might but someone
talked about we don't make millions uh
and i work with them very good
advertising for you as well
it's again
my job is to get people in a good place
so to try and raise the conversation a
bit into something lighter is um when
i've done this work what i've found is
it's amazing how people once they start
understanding themselves and actually
start managing uh their emotions
the change in the life is fantastic so i
can't count the number of people and it
is humbling that go through this work
that i'm doing and say it's
transformational once you understand
yourself and you can manage your
emotions and your thinking and your
behaviors you just change into the
person you really are and suddenly
you're free of all this
so it all the stuff we've talked about
is almost secondary to what i do so when
people come in whatever's happening just
put even the illness to one side and
let's work on you as a person
and i've obviously had the privilege
you're working with a lot of people that
are well known uh i can't name names
unless they've gone public because
obviously i'm a doctor and um but the
two that did interviews early days with
ronnie sullivan in snooker and vicki
pendleton on the bike
both fantastic people um and it was
interesting they both didn't interview
the press at the same time without
knowing uh they were doing it and both
said the same thing when steve met us he
didn't go to the snooker table or the
track
he came to us as people and said let's
get you in a good place and when i got
them in a good place dennis said what do
you want to do with yourself now then
we're gonna have a look at cycling in a
circle or we'll look at knocking a ball
around you know then i'll say okay let's
apply what you've done now but let's
start in a good place and all of us all
of us can get in a good place the games
give you some healthy good research
every bit of research shows if you
actually work on yourself emotionally
you will improve you will improve it's
just getting something that resonates
with you i've put out the chimp model
because it's what i find resonates with
me and those who resonates with great
but if you've got people listening and
think it doesn't resonate with me
there's so many other alternatives that
are brilliant that you could resonate
with and it's that thing of certainly
believing that you can actually do this
and get out there maybe get someone to
help you and support you
we can all improve so every bit of
research shows emotional skills can be
learned
and then your quality life improves
so again when i look at the people on
the telly the answer is no
i haven't found this but i'm only one
man
you have to ask the people who normally
do it for life the sports psychologist
they're the experts and if you ask them
they may come up with something very
different my experience has been the
people i've worked with uh are just
everyday people who happen to be able to
either run quickly or kick a ball or you
know they just have a special physical
gift but mentally they're the same as we
are
and they struggle with the same things
we struggle with
and that's really interesting yeah i
haven't found the x-men yeah i haven't
found that well this time this fits
nicely with what i've always believed
since a pretty young age which is it's
really important to work on yourself on
your mental game as well as all sorts of
other things that you do
um and i have always i've always found
that that is a process that you get
rewarded for yeah and i never thought
that i i'm necessarily destined for some
kind of special thing i just didn't want
to live my life knowing that there's
something in the way
that
i think that's something which is where
we're going back to the neuroscience
which in the 90s i had this light bulb
moment that i'm talking to these
patients think there's two people
talking to me
and it sort of dawned on me just you
talk and then they talk almost like
emotional rubbish and you think and then
suddenly i bring them around and they
talk sensibly and think it's a different
person suddenly it's quite severe the
difference and that's where i started
looking at the science thinking let's go
with my experience and see is this born
out with neuroscience and there it was
in front of me
you've got these two parts of the brain
almost in a battle if you don't manage
them and exactly what you're saying what
you're really saying to me and the
neurosciences my computer needed tidying
up because it's sabotaging with all
these beliefs that are not helping me
and also that this active chimp brain
is just jumping me around and it's got
its own agenda and ways of working which
i don't actually agree with
so i'm going to slow it down and stop it
being impulsive so that's when you
explain i'm getting in the way of myself
that's all i'm saying scientifically is
if you start distancing yourself from
the the chimp and computer and learn who
you really are
because most people don't have a clue
who they are and then you say right what
you're presenting to the world is you
within influence from the chimp and
computer or even a hijack when you get
that then you would not say to me
i am an anxious person
what you'd say is i'm actually a really
peaceful easygoing
very relaxed person because that's who
you'd want to be but when they bolt on
this
machine
my machine's crazy and i need to learn
to understand and work with it and get
it on board
so it will always present anxiety
that's not going to stop
but what you'll learn to do is when you
distance from it's learning what it's
trying to tell you what you need to do
to sort your computer out and then
you'll find that sometimes it just
doesn't happen
because it happens so fast in the brain
it's like less than a fifth of a second
that your computer will settle the chimp
all you've got to do is input
and see what resonates with you and then
you start saying i'm fine my chimp's
anxious
we start seeing as a positive that
brings up a question for me i said we're
going to end on a positive or probably
not now
which is
what do you make of the increasing
medicalization of some of these feelings
that we experience you've got anxiety
here's a tablet you've got depression
here's a tablet and we we don't say you
feel depressed we say you have this
thing called depression
what do you make of of that because i
found
like you say this sometimes anxiety is
there for a reason exactly anxiety is
telling you you're not ready for this
you need to go in and train or prepare
or learn or or not do this because this
is the wrong thing for you absolutely
right
but if if the answer we have as a
society to that is shove it down here's
a tablet to make it all go away is that
going to get in the way of us growing as
people
i think so i think the problem you've
got is you think about this i mean
we're overloaded in in the world of
mental health and psyches and so i think
you talk to anyone who's counseling a
psychologist uh psychiatrist were
overloaded therapists are overloaded
because all of us could do with this
because like mental coaching you know
it's getting us to understand because
nobody tells us this
so we're not given a manual at birth
that says this is what you're going to
have to manage
so we find it and we don't know what to
do with it so we we don't then have
healthy behaviors for coping strategies
so it is
the doctors gps are overloaded so they
can't sit down and say to you let's
start analyzing what you're thinking
let's see what you believe so they can't
do that they've got seven minutes
exactly so therefore it's much easier to
look take this tablet go for a walk go
swimming do this
because it's a quick fix and i hope
that'll just calm you down but it's a
sticky plaster so you're right
uh we're complex beings and we we have
to put the effort in but we also need
people who know what they're doing to
help us to to find out what's going on
our heads and and we don't have enough
people to do that
hence i wrote the book to try and say
you can work this out for yourself and
there are things you can do practically
that will get you into a good place but
i know where you're coming from you're
sort of like pushing me to
say that we're labeling lots of things
medical and now you do agree you know
sometimes we're labeling teenagers when
they they're going through a normal
hormonal change which is going to send
you emotions everywhere you're learning
to do interpersonal skills and you've
got no experience uh and you've also got
this troop drive saying you must be
loved by everyone and any comment can
destroy you and and so that is normal so
to be a teenager is not a good place for
most teenagers
but you know we have to be careful that
the the small subgroup that have a
depressive illness 100 don't get lost
100 you're right we there is and we have
concerns of psychiatrists about this
that we're medicalizing a bit too much
and saying look this is not medical it's
normal what we need to learn which is
why i said at the beginning my patients
have come through the door fifty percent
probably do need medication fifty
percent of referrals that i got from gp
did not need that they needed insights
and learn how to manage
and we know like for example anxiety
that you've mentioned that uh that
doesn't respond to medication
you can knock it down a bit but it don't
it won't be removed with medication it's
removed by actually seeing what's
causing anxiety and what your beliefs
are so it is a a mind problem as opposed
to physical illness
so anxiety
yeah it to me it's it's um
a lack of management and we need to look
and say how can we help people to get
that management
and then they'll come out of it so we do
a lot of cognitive behavioral type work
without rather than give tablets
i do agree i do agree with you
steve it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on the show
we're going to do a few quick questions
okay for our locals members uh before we
do that we always have one final
question which is what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be
i think it alludes back to the children
in schools and work doing a lot of work
schools at the moment and looking at
building resilience and robustness in
children because we know the researchers
do it at four-year-old there are ways we
can actually improve
resilience in four to five-year-olds
which pay dividends 10 years on and the
research shows that that you can get
resilient teenagers which is what we're
after and resilient adults so for me the
big thing is um what i'm doing and
that's trying to get people to become
psychologically minded and start
understanding themselves as a human
being and having a better opinion of
themselves build themselves up and
others that's where i think i'd like to
see society going we need to be talking
much more about positive not
you know using it as a safety net but
saying how do we get positive and
proactive uh really get quality life in
a good place that's what i feel we
should be talking about yeah i couldn't
agree more i think we talk so much about
mental health and what we really talk
about is mental ill health what we
should be talking about so much more is
tuning your brain up to to be better to
be more fulfilled to be more successful
to be happier to be psychological health
yeah exactly teach relationships
communication dealing with emotion this
kind of stuff i'd like to see yeah much
earlier on in schools well what one of
the great things about a path through
the jungle and your other work but
particularly this one is you've kind of
got very easy to to to read you've got
graphs and all sorts of other things are
visually engaging that makes them more
digestible so i really recommend you
guys check out the chin paradox and the
path through the jungle dr steve peters
thanks so much for coming thank you so
much thank you
i'm a massive ronnie o'sullivan fan and
i've heard steve used to be in his
dressing room at big tournaments what
did he say to him in the middle of the
day
i couldn't
i spoke to him two days